to get my car here is not possible you
really have to hike
this restaurant has been perched in a
swiss alps for 173 years and the trek
has always attracted hungry hikers but
it's steep
nearly 5 000 feet up
hello and welcome to the asher
[Music]
i'm melanie quinder and i'm the manager
of the restaurant our food is very
traditional we got like sausage cheese
salad or not croissant
but before you make any orders here's
how to get there
first get to the canton of appenzell
inner rodden and head to vasarowan
then cable car it you'll go up a
distance of over 2000 feet to the
evernote mountain once you get there
have your hiking boots ready for 15
minutes deep hike go through a 40 000
year old cave pass a chapel
and you're there
or you can take a two hour hike through
other
paths the most hardest part is like the
infrastructure
every chair beer all the food everything
has to come by cable car
if there is anything really big and
heavy we're gonna use the helicopter
we got electricity from the cable car we
got the fresh water from the snow and
the rain in a cave is a big pot of water
and when this is empty we have to buy
the water
so i got a team in the service the
kitchen and i got people who do all the
transports
[Music]
and me
[Music]
for me it's like a really special
feeling to be here my favorite part of
the day is when i'm standing up getting
coffee and just sitting out of the
terrace it's just quiet
and it's just relaxing
most people came here they are really
happy they are
they feel the magic so you wake up and
you see
everything it's just unbelievable every
time i get tears just wow
you